Okay, so good morning. Um today this
morning we are doing the Byzantine
Empire. And I will be looking at three
questions.
The first question is why do we have the
Byzantine Empire?
Um historically we have
seen
the Byzantine Empire as a continuation
of the Roman Empire.
We have the Byzantine Empire because
Constantine the Great in 330
um
transferred the capital of the Roman
Empire from Rome
to Byzantium, which later became which
which he called New Rome and which
eventually was renamed to
Constantinople.
So why did he make that transition?
Okay, that's the first question. Second
question is
how did the Byzantine Empire rise?
It fell it lasted from
um 330 until 1453
when the Ottoman Turks overran
the uh capital of Constantinople. So
lasted for 1,000 years. Arguably it is
the most enduring world empire in human
history.
So how was it so successful? That's the
that's the second question.
Now the third and last question is why
did it ultimately ultimately decline?
Why did it collapse? What were the
factors let that led to its eventual
demise.
Okay, so those are the three questions
we will we will be looking at um this
morning.
And what I want to do first I I want to
present the scholarly consensus. What is
generally accepted, what is generally
believed about these three questions,
and then I want to present my own
perspective
um in order to
uh refute the scholarly consensus.
All right, so let's start.
Um this is the Roman Empire in 117.
And as you can see it is huge. It It
spans across the Mediterranean.
Uh this is Spain over here is
um
Anatolia
Egypt, the Levant. Okay, so it is a huge
world empire and that's the problem.
It's just much too big.
Um unlike China
um
it has no natural boundaries. And
throughout most of its history
it
uh was invaded by
barbarians. What what the Romans call
barbarians. Basically these Germanic
Gothic tribes from the north. It also
had a major adversary in the Persian
Empire uh
at this time they were fighting against
the Parthians
uh but later on they were fighting
against what is what we call the
Sasanian Persian Empire.
Um
and so this was not a really sustainable
empire. Internally
as we discussed last class there was a
contradiction.
They were an empire
but they believed themselves to be a
republic.
It was important for them to maintain
republican institutions like the Senate
even though
um it was to the detriment of the
management of the empire. What I mean by
that is that throughout this time
on paper in theory it was committee
it was ruled by committee.
Okay, the Senate was really in command.
And as we discussed in previous classes
the Senate is composed
of the Roman aristocracy, the ruling
houses of Rome.
When you have that when you have
committee ruled by committee
um when power is divided up evenly among
the ruling houses of an empire the only
thing they can really agree on is to be
corrupt together.
And so the Senate was a huge problem
because they basically monopolized
wealth.
And there was a lot of discontent in the
provinces. There was a lot of disconnect
among the people.
And the Romans tried different solutions
to this.
Um but none of the solutions worked.
And in
and eventually we had something called
the third century crisis, the crisis of
the third century, which basically
meant the Roman Empire was about to
disintegrate. There were civil wars
going on.
Uh there were these invasions from the
north.
Uh there was economic collapse. There's
a plague. So in the third century
um there it really seemed the Roman
Empire was on the brink of complete
implosion.
Then uh military genius by name of uh
Diocletian he re- re- re- united the
empire and he recognized
we basically needed to change the
system.
And we needed to make radical changes in
order to save the Roman Empire. Okay?
Um
as you can see it is extremely difficult
to protect Rome against um the barbarian
invaders over time. Eventually the
western portion of the empire will be
overrun
by
uh these barbarians who we call the
Germanics, the Goths, the Slavs, the
Huns, okay? Basically these are the
successors to the Germanic people. And
they come from the steppes. And so they
are extremely aggressive
uh
mobile people
um who will eventually overrun the Roman
Empire and they will establish
um
basically the tribes that will
eventually give us the modern states of
Germany
um
Britain, France. Okay, so basically
these are the ancestors of western
Europeans.
All right.
Um
as
um so as you can see these
um barbarians they will establish their
own empires and all that will be left
after the year about the year 500 is the
Eastern Roman Empire which is the
successor
uh to the uh Roman Empire. Okay, and
um even though they can call themselves
Romans
and they identify themselves as Romans
historians refer to to the to the
Eastern Roman Empire as the Byzantines,
okay? They don't they don't again they
did they themselves did not call
themselves the Byzantine Byzantines.
It's what later historians call them.
Okay.
So the man who makes this transition
uh who basically is the founder of the
Byzantine Empire, his name is
Constantine the Great. And what he does
that's very important is that he shifts
the capital
from Rome to Byzantium on the Bosphorus.
And today we call this place
Constantinople. It's still there guys if
you want to visit. It's called Istanbul
in in in Turkey and it's a beautiful
city. Uh definitely one of the most
beautiful cities in the world.
Now the question is sorry uh I skipped.
The question then is why was this move
made? And what modern historians uh
believe is that this was a strategic
decision.
Um first of all Rome was not easily
defended. So it's very common throughout
its history for it to be overrun by
provincial military governor. Okay, so
think of Julius Caesar but also there
were others as well who did the same
thing, who were extremely successful in
the provinces and they took their
military and conquered Rome. It was very
easy to overrun Rome and then declare
himself
uh emperor. So by moving into
Constantinople um he the city the
capital is now impenetrable. Okay, it is
impossible to besiege. Uh it is easily
defensible and how so I will show you
later on, okay? The other thing that's
really important about this transition
is
Constantinople is really at the center
of the empire now. Rome was too far to
the west and most of
um the Roman Empire's most wealthy
provinces, the most important provinces
like Egypt, Anatolia, and the Levant
were actually in the east.
Okay, so it's recognition of the fact
the center of gravity
um in the empire was really in the east.
And the third reason is again
throughout most of its history Rome's
main competitor were the Persian Empire
to the east. And so by moving to
Constantinople it allows the emperor to
most easily and most directly respond to
the threat of the Persians. Okay, so
this is the scholarly consensus. Okay.
Um but as I will show you later on I
disagree with this consensus. I think
there was a much more important reason
why Constantine made this move. Okay? Um
The
Byzantine Empire becomes this the
um birthplace of modern Christianity.
Okay, Constantine the Great is the first
Christian Roman Empire emperor. He
converts to Christianity. But not only
that but he lays the intellectual basis
for modern Christianity for something
called the Council of Nicaea Ni- Ni-
Nicaea. The the pronunciation is
different, okay? It's properly
pronounced Nicaea but most people
pronounce it Nicaea, okay? So the
Council of Nicaea. We talked about this
last semester where the Council of
Nicaea was established to answer
a theological debate in the Christian
world. What is the nature of Jesus? What
is his relationship with God? As we
discussed,
one of the more popular interpretations,
explanations is the idea of Arianism
where Jesus is a lesser divinity to God.
The Council of Nicaea, Nikaia,
established the idea of the Holy Trinity
which is that
God, Jesus, and the Holy Spirit are
co-equal. They are separate, but they
are co-equal. We call this the Holy
Trinity, the Godhead.
Okay?
So, that was Constantine's major
contribution.
Um
after Constantine, his one of his
successors, Theodosius,
makes Christianity the official religion
of the Roman Empire. There's now a
crackdown on both the idea of paganism,
which used to be the religion of the
Roman Empire, as well as the idea of
heresy, okay, especially the idea of
Arianism.
Um he also builds something called the
Theodosian Walls, which makes
Constantinople basically impenetrable,
okay? It makes it a impenetrable
fortress and allows it Constantinople to
stand for a thousand years. Okay, as you
can see from the
Theodosian Walls,
um it's huge, okay? This is just a
person. You can see that there are two
walls. There's a moat protecting it.
Um so, for 5000 years, these walls
protected the city. There weren't that
many soldiers within the city. You
didn't need actually need that many
soldiers to protect against invaders.
The other thing, so uh these walls are
still standing today. You can actually
go, get on a plane, fly to Istanbul and
visit these walls. Okay? They were They
were basically designed to stand for all
of eternity.
And that was the idea of Constantinople,
the eternal city.
Um
they also had sea walls. So, not only
could you not attack Constantinople from
by land, you couldn't even attack it by
sea.
One of the great inventions
um of Constantinople is the idea of
Greek fire. Okay, the story is
that um they were being attacked by the
Muslims. This is in the 8th century when
uh the Muslims are expanding throughout
the world. They're conquering uh both
the Sassanian Empire as well as the
uh Roman Empire, and they want to ob-
obviously overrun Constantinople.
And And ultimately, what saves the city
is invention of something called Greek
fire, which is basically kerosene,
right? You take kerosene, you throw it
at someone, and then the boat um is lit
on fire. The story is that this was
invented by a Hellenized Jew who
converted to Christianity.
And he he has this great idea, and then
he approaches the emperor with this uh
invention. The emperor believes that he
is an angel sent by God to save the
city.
Okay? And
so, it is impossible to actually launch
a naval expedition against
Constantinople because they'll just burn
down your ships.
Okay?
Um at the height of the Byzantine
Empire, it almost reestablishes,
reconstitutes the entire Roman uh
Empire. And this is the year 565. At
this point, the emperor is Justinian,
and at this point, the one who's leading
the military
of the Byzantines, his name is
Belisarius, and he's considered the last
great Roman general, okay? His military
genius is on par with that of Julius
Caesar, Hannibal, all the great
generals.
And through his military conquests, but
the Byzantine Empire
um is able to expand its influence.
But as we learn in this class, once you
reach a peak of empire, there are
problems, okay? So, the first problem is
that your city becomes overpopulated,
and when your city becomes
overpopulated, it becomes susceptible to
the plague, okay? So, there's something
called the Justinian Plague, which wiped
out anywhere between 50 to 60% of the
entire population of Constantinople.
At this point, uh the population
population of the city is about 500,000,
half a million. The plague killed
300,000 people. That's a lot of people,
okay? Even today, scholars debate where
this plague came from. Originally, we
believed it came from grain ships from
Egypt, right? Because Constantinople
imports all its food from Egypt. And so,
there were rats on these ships, and
these rats spread basically the bubonic
plague.
Now, historians believe that it actually
came from the steppes, the Huns, and
through their invasion, okay? So, we
don't know what happened. We just know
uh
we we just know it killed a lot of
people, and this greatly
uh reduced the power of uh the empire.
Also, when you have these military
military conquests, you're
over-overextended,
okay? So, it is very difficult to
maintain this empire.
And the third problem is that whenever
there's a military expansion, the
empire, the emperor comes in conflict
with a general. So, even though
Justinian and Belisarius, they were
great friends, their wives were great
friends, they themselves had a lot of
personal conflict. In fact, um towards
the end of his life, Belisarius was
actually tried for treason.
And there were many times when
Belisarius was on a military campaign,
and it was clear that Justinian was
trying to sabotage him because
obviously, if you're emperor, uh you're
afraid that uh your general, your great
conquering general, will eventually come
back and take your throne.
Okay?
So, because of what happened between
Justinian and Belisarius, basically,
this was the last time that the
Byzantines uh embarked on a massive
military campaign.
Okay? From now on, they're defensive,
and also, they focus on the idea of
diplomacy, basically bribing their
enemies not to attack them, especially
the Huns,
uh but also the Arabs as well as the
Persian Empire.
Okay?
This is the Hagia Sophia, the cathedral
to wisdom, and this is the great
monument,
uh the great legacy of the Byzantine
Empire. It's It's absolutely beautiful.
Again, guys, this is what This is what's
amazing. It's still there.
Okay? You can actually get on a plane,
go to Istanbul, and visit this place.
It's absolutely It's absolutely
gorgeous.
Um definitely worth visiting.
All right.
Now, why did
Constantinople
fall?
Um and
so, what happened was that again, even
though Constantinople itself is
impenetrable, it's invincible,
um it's still it's still an empire. And
so, eventually, its regions were
eventually overrun by greater enemies.
So, for example, in about the year 1450,
and this is three years before the
eventual fall of the of the city,
uh the Ottoman Empire just It's
basically taking taking over the
Byzantines, okay? And the only city left
standing is Constantinople, okay? So,
you can see over here are the Ottomans.
Over here is the Ottomans.
Okay?
The Ottomans were able to conquer the
city because of the invention of siege
engines, okay? These are These cannons
are as big as houses, and they basically
overwhelm the walls and allow the
Ottomans to overrun the city.
Now, what's important to understand is
even though the Byzantines were
Christian, and the Ottomans were Muslim,
and even though
uh the Turks
overran the city, the Turks were
extremely respectful
to the citizens of the city
because they were considered the heirs,
the successors to the Roman Empire.
Uh and this was the center of what we
call the Orthodox Church. So, the So,
So, the citizens were treated extremely
well, okay?
Um this again is another picture of the
Siege of Constantinople. All right.
Let's talk lastly about
um the significance and power of the
city. The city was the center of the
world for hundreds of years, both
intellectually, because it again, it was
the heir to not just the Roman Empire,
but also to Greek civilization.
Um it was also, in terms of trade, the
capital the world because it was a
meeting place of both the Aegean, which
leads to the Mediterranean, as well as
the Black Sea, which leads into
um
what what is Russia today.
Okay? So, if you want to go anywhere,
you basically had to go through
Constantinople. It was really the center
of the world, and through trade, and
taxing trade, the city became extremely
wealthy. Also, because it was the center
of the world, it was very multicultural,
very cosmopolitan. You had basically all
major ethnicities living inside the
city. Jews, Christians, Muslims were all
treated with extreme tolerance.
They basically had their own quarters
within the city.
Okay? As you can see at its height, the
city was extremely beautiful
and very wealthy. It was really for 400
years the capital of the world, the
capital of the universe, basically.
Um
as you can see, it is almost impossible
to besiege. Okay? You You can never cut
it off from supplies. You can never
isolate the city because it is the
meeting place of so many rivers. Okay?
This is the Bosphorus.
Okay? So, that is the Roman Empire.
Okay? Um
so, this is the again, what we know
about it. And now I'm going to explain
um
my theory to these three questions.
Why did Constantine make the move from
Rome to Byzantium? Why did it rise? Why
did it decline? Okay? But before I start
uh with my explanation, are there any
questions about what I just presented?
This is all pretty basic stuff. This is
stuff you can find on the internet um on
Wikipedia. You can ask Chat GPT, they'll
probably give you the same answers.
Okay? But are there any questions so far
about
uh Constantinople and the Byzantine
Empire before I I I I present my ideas?
Was this clear to you guys?
Any Any questions, guys?
Maybe this is something you're coming up
to. So, so if it is, like,
shoot the question down. But, uh
I I remember reading like in the early
years of the the Roman Empire, the the
the like you know, Augustus, Tiberius,
uh
so on. The elite culture there was
Greek.
And that
like the um
and so so like the the Emperor Claudius
would have been writing and conversing
in
in Greek and all that kind of stuff. Uh
and so
like like like I moved I know the move
to uh
Constantinople is a couple of hundred
years after. But
was there a certain cultural pull at the
time where where where certain Roman
elites feeling like they needed to be
closer to
like the core Greek culture? Right.
Okay. That's a good question. So,
culturally, were the Romans at this time
Greek or Roman?
Um
and you're actually right, Doc, in that
Greek culture
is really the hegemon, all right? I
mean, it's
so many so much so superior to Roman
culture. I mean, Romans really were
peasants
uh who built an empire. But the Greeks
uh basically built Western civilization.
Okay? You had Homer, you had Plato, you
had Herodotus. The The The Romans were
aware of this. And this was a conflict
within Roman culture civilization for a
long long time because they felt that
even though they had conquered the
world, they were about to be cult
conquered culturally by the Greeks. So,
the Romans were aware of this and they
rebelled against this. And um
you weren't here for my lecture on the
Aeneid. But really, uh Augustus Caesar
sponsors the writing of the Aeneid in
response
to the hegemony of of Greek culture. So,
even though you're right in that most of
the Roman aristocracy, they embraced
Greek culture,
uh such as like Mark Antony, right? Uh
Mark Antony saw himself as more Greek
than than than Roman.
Um there was a lot of pushback from the
empire against this.
Okay? So, um but eventually, as we'll
see, eventually Greek culture does
triumph. All right.
So, so so let me explain how. All right.
So, the first question I want to look at
is why did Constantine make the move
from
um
Rome to Byzantium. Okay? So, let me give
you some background.
So,
um during the time of Augustus,
Augustus, we we we today see him as the
first Roman emperor. But we he did not
himself see himself as the first
emperor. He just saw himself as just a
citizen of Rome. Okay? He He's what we
call a princep or he calls himself a
princep. And this is where we get the um
modern English word prince as well as
principal, high school principal.
And it just means first first citizen.
So, again, the problem with Rome is that
you had the aristocracy
uh through the Senate monopolize all
wealth and power.
And this led to a lot of contradictions
and conflicts within the Roman Empire.
And so, the solution
that Augustus proposed is make the
princep, make me the CEO. Okay? This is
It's still committee. It's still ruled
by committee, but I'll be the
coordinator. I'll be the CEO.
Okay? And the idea here was even though
this was not a great system, it did
preserve the culture, okay? The history,
the legacy,
uh and the traditions of the Roman
people. And that was what was important
to protect and preserve the
uh culture, especially the idea of
libertas,
okay? Liberty.
Um but this system didn't really work.
Right? You had these civil wars, you had
a lot of provincial
uh riots,
um rebellions. So, this So, this system
simply didn't work and this led to what
we call the crisis of the 3rd century
when basically the Roman Empire was
about to collapse. Okay? And again, we
as we said, and a governor, a a
commander named Diocletian, he saved the
Roman Empire by reuniting. Okay? And at
this point, he's like, this system
doesn't work. What we need to do is
study the Persian Empire.
Because even though we don't like the
Persians, their their empire seems a lot
more sustainable and continuous than our
empire. Okay?
And so, this started a period what what
we call the dominate. Okay? Basically,
the idea of starting an imperial
bureaucracy, centralizing power
uh with the emperor through the
bureaucracy.
And the Romans hated this idea.
Okay? What What What emperors discovered
is this cultural shift
um what The Romans just found actually
disgusting. Go back to the assassination
of Juli- assassination of Julius Caesar.
Right? The The Romans were extremely
culturally arrogant. Why did they
assassinate Julius Caesar? And the
people who assassinated Julius Caesar
were his best friends.
In fact, we believe Marcus Brutus, who
was one of the lead conspirators, was
actually his biological son.
Right? Why? Because Julius Caesar was
threatening the cultural traditions of
Rome. They were afraid that Julius
Caesar would become king.
So, what these emperors uh first under
Diocletian, but especially under
Constantine, discovered is it's really
hard to change culture.
And there's really one solution to this
problem.
Okay? To understand this,
let's let's run a thought experiment.
Okay?
Okay, so you understand the persistence
of culture.
Okay, so we're at a at at at school and
this school is known for being
innovative. It's It's known for
being student-centered. It focuses a lot
on activities and extracurriculars,
right? And that's great. I'm very
supportive of this.
But let's just say
that
uh the school brings me in as a
consultant and asks me to help improve
the school. And I do a lot I spend
months interviewing students and
teachers. I I feel
the school is great in terms of
innovation, but it needs to focus more
on academics.
Kids need to read more.
Kids need to focus more on
um test scores.
And then you have a perfect balance,
okay? And that's my solution.
Well,
I'm pretty sure if I tried that,
um I'd be fired within a week.
Okay? And the reason why is I am
attacking your cultural traditions. I'm
attacking your identity, your sense of
self.
So, if I want to implement my vision,
I can't force my vision on you. The only
thing I can really do is switch schools
and build my own school. Okay? Does that
make sense to you guys? Okay? And this
is This is uh a pretty persistent uh
thing throughout the world, okay? So,
that's why Constantine
made the move to Byzantium. He
recognized that if I'm going to build an
empire and Rome needs to be an empire if
it is to endure,
I need to switch cultures. And the best
way to switch culture is by moving your
capital from Rome to Byzantium.
And when he did that,
the entire culture shifted. Okay? So, so
let me very quickly explain the cultural
shift. In Rome,
it was
pagan.
Okay?
Oh, by the way, um pagan is not the word
that they use, okay? Pagan is the word
that Christians use to insult them,
basically, okay? But But But for the
sake of convenience, we'll use the word
pagan.
Uh that was their religion. They were
Roman, meaning that they had a distinct
cultural identity.
And lastly, they were republic,
meaning they were run by the Senate,
basically, okay? Not just Senate, but by
tradition and uh by custom, okay?
By Constantinople, okay? The Byzantine
Empire was completely different. First
of all, it was Christian.
And the pagan and Christian worldview
are in conflict with each other. This is
a major shift. Second is they were
multicultural.
So, as Stuck says,
um
in the time of Rome, the time of
Augustus, there's a major conflict,
major debate uh between Roman culture
and Greek culture. But when they shift
switch over to Constantinople, they
completely embrace Greek culture.
In fact,
the language switched from being Roman
to Greek.
They spoke Greek.
And they embraced Greek culture.
Herodotus, Plato,
uh were major
thinkers that the that the
um Byzantine Empire embraced and
celebrated.
And lastly, it switched from from a
republic, meaning that it went
uh being run by Senate, to an empire.
Which basically meant it was being run
by a bureaucracy.
Okay?
So,
Byzantine the Byzantine Empire
is a very distinct entity from the Roman
Empire. Historians today argue the
Byzantine Empire is continuation
of
the Roman Empire,
but that's only a superficial and
shallow understanding. Culturally, the
Byzantine Empire was a radical departure
from the Roman Empire or the Roman
Republic. Okay? And so, I will explain
what these differences are. And and this
is it's very important because it's
going to inform our understanding of
future events in Western civilization,
okay? So, let me first explain the
difference in worldview between the
pagan and the Christian.
All right?
All right, pagan.
And again, guys, I will have to make a
lot of generalizations, but it's a
useful framework for the understanding
of
um ancient cultures, okay? So, so what's
the pagan worldview?
Well, in the pagan worldview, there are
different layers to your understanding
of the world.
The force is supernatural forces that
you interact with intimately are the
gods.
Okay?
And the gods is really a metaphorical
way to understand nature.
Right? So,
um
in nature, there are all these natural
forces
that we can't really see. For example,
the wind. We can't really see the wind,
but also we can't really see creativity
or luck.
Well, in the pagan worldview, these
hidden invisible forces are rendered and
expressed as gods.
Okay? And the gods are those that we
interact with everyday on an intimate
basis. It was very important for us to
maintain good relations with the gods by
making ritual tributes to the gods.
Okay? So, sacrifice and rituals were a
very important part of the pagan
worldview.
Above the gods are actually even
higher invisible forces
that no one has control of, okay? In
which this which includes fate,
which includes luck, okay, fortune,
okay? But they're all they're all but
there are these invisible forces
that even the gods must submit to.
And then,
at the highest level,
are what are called um
unwritten
and immutable. Immutable just means
unable to change, eternal, laws of the
universe. And think of this structure as
giving the universe some order and
structure.
Okay, so think of gravity.
Right? It's it's an unwritten in the
middle in the middle law of the
universe. And what they really mean by
this is the idea really of karma or
justice.
Right? If you do good in the world, good
will happen to you. If you do evil in
the world, evil will happen to you. It
may not happen to you, but it may happen
to your children, okay? So, there is a
cosmic balance
to the world. And this is really the
pagan worldview, right?
The Christian worldview is very simple.
There's you, okay? You, and then there's
God. And the thing that matters is your
personal relationship with God. That's
it, guys.
All right? So,
let's look at the three major
differences between the pagan worldview
and the Christian worldview. Okay? And
again, this is a generalized simplified
version, and we use it in order um to be
clear about the differences and that
there are in fact differences.
All right. So, the three major
differences are this.
The Christian worldview introduces into
uh the Roman world three ideas that
really didn't exist before. Okay? They
are truth,
evil,
and the individual.
Now, these ideas actually existed in
other traditions, like the Jewish
tradition and the Persian tradition
through Zoroastrianism, but they really
didn't exist in the Greek and the Roman
tradition.
So, the counterpart to truth in the
pagan tradition is the idea of
um chaos or luck.
Okay?
So, there's no structure to the
universe. In the Christian worldview,
there's a God who has designed the
universe, and that is the truth.
Okay? So, the intention of God is the
truth. The plan is the truth. Whereas in
the pagan worldview, there's no design,
guys. It's just complete random chaos,
and you just have to do try your best in
this world, okay?
In the Christian worldview, it's the
idea of evil, which is if you go against
the intention of God, if you commit sin,
that is evil.
Now, what's interesting for us is in the
pagan worldview, the opposite idea is
action.
Okay?
In other words, in the world of chaos,
you have to act.
You have to do stuff.
If you refuse to act, you are a slave.
So, think back to the Iliad. Right? In
In the Iliad, Achilles says why he is in
Troy, why he's fighting in Troy.
And he says that before he came to Troy,
he was told his fate. He could either
die
old
back at home,
or he could die young
in Troy.
But
by dying young in Troy, he'd become
famous.
He'd be remembered forever.
And for Achilles, that's not really a
choice. What he's being told is, you
must come to Troy, and you must
die, and that will win you eternal
glory.
Okay? It's the idea of
action.
Also, think of the Romans, okay? In
their legends, they have they have a
name name Mucius.
Remember at at the beginning of the
Roman Republic,
the Romans are besieged by the Etruscan
king.
And Mucius is a young Roman man, only 20
years old, he decides to assassinate the
king in order to free the Romans. He
swims across the Tiber,
and he's about to do his deed, but it's
payday, and the king is with his
secretary.
And they look alike. They dress alike,
they look alike.
And Mucius is hiding with his dagger,
and he knows it's 50/50, okay?
Now, for us, we'd be like, "You know
what? 50/50 is terrible odds. So, let me
come back another day, or let me be more
patient."
But for Mucius, it's fortune favors the
bold. So, he's like, "50/50 is great is
great odds. I'm never getting better
odds." So, he takes his he takes his
um dagger, and he kills the secretary,
okay? He misses.
Then he's captured by the king,
and the king wants to torture him and
force him to confess.
And the king starts interrogating him
and says, "I will burn you alive." Okay,
there's a great fire beside Mucius.
"If you do not tell me the truth."
And what Mucius does is he puts his hand
into the fire and lets it burn in front
of the king. And that scares the king.
Okay? That's the idea of action.
You make your fortune through your
action.
You cannot sit and wait. You cannot
deliberate. You cannot be clever. You
just act. You're just brave, okay?
That's a pagan worldview. This is
important for us because
the um people who will in future in our
course, who's very important, and who
follows this worldview, are also the
Vikings, okay? So, the Vikings share
this similar worldview. It's a pagan
worldview.
The last thing is the idea
in the Christian worldview, it's the
individual that matters. The
individual's individual soul is what
matters.
Okay?
But in the pagan worldview, what matters
is the community.
Why are Achilles
Why is Achilles fighting in Troy? Why is
Mucius
sacrificing himself for Rome? Because
they want to be remembered by the
community.
All right? So, let me give you two
examples of this.
Let's go back to to the Iliad. Hector.
Remember Hector?
Hector in the Iliad, he is the greatest
Trojan warrior, and he's destroying the
Greeks because Achilles refuses to
fight.
But then Achilles
enters the battlefield and at this point
Hector's lieutenant tells him, "Hector,
Achilles is back.
Let's go home. Let's go hide behind the
walls of Troy. We'll be fine."
But Hector says, "No.
Fortune favors the bold. The gods are
with me."
And so of course Achilles and the Greeks
destroy the Trojans. And they all have
to and they're all forced to run back to
the walls of Troy.
Every woman enters Troy except for
Hector. Hector stays outside the walls
of Troy and waits for Achilles to come.
He knows for a fact that Achilles will
kill him. Achilles is a god.
He's a great warrior, but he's not a
god.
And at this point he knows he's about to
to be killed and most of us would just
sneak back into the walls of Troy,
right?
He can't do that because he's afraid of
being
laughed at
by his lieutenant.
He's afraid of shame.
He has to die for his community.
Okay? So, that's Hector.
But also think about Lucretia.
Lucretia
Lucretia, remember, is the woman
noblewoman who is raped by the son of
Tarquinius
Superbus, the last king of Rome. And
this is what starts the rebellion that
overthrew the Roman monarchy.
Lucretia is raped and then she kills
herself
because she's dishonored.
And Augustine, remember Augustine in
City of God, he writes about this.
Okay?
And from his perspective
it was a crime for Lucretia to kill
herself. Why? Because we are all the
creation of God. Therefore, we are the
property of God. Therefore, when we kill
ourself when we kill ourselves, we're
committing
a sin against God.
We are basically stealing from God. And
that's why if you commit suicide, you'll
be condemned to hell
forever, okay? You'll be condemned to
damnation forever.
And then
Augustine explains Lucretia killed
herself because she's afraid of the
shame that she would have to endure if
she lived. She was She was afraid that
she'd be laughed at by the other women
of of Rome, okay? And that's the idea of
community versus the individual.
All right?
Okay.
So,
this So, it's a radically different
worldview, the pagan versus the
Christian. Let me explain some other
differences. For example, the attitude
towards sex.
Okay?
Christians, because we live in a
Christian world, we know that sex is
bad.
Okay? Sex should only happen
between husband and wife and it should
only happen for the purpose of
procreation.
We shouldn't do it because we enjoy it.
The pagans had the complete opposite
attitude towards sex. Sex was to be
embraced. It was to be enjoyed. It was
to be celebrated.
Why? Because
if it if the gods didn't mean for us to
have sex, they wouldn't make it so much
fun.
Okay? So, sex was a very important part
of pagan
life. As well as violence, okay? They
also embraced and celebrated violence.
Okay, so think about the Vikings. Think
about the Romans, right?
They loved violence. And the Christians
hated violence.
So,
the argument is that the Christian
worldview is an improvement on the pagan
worldview because the pagans they had
things like orgies. They had things like
child sacrifice. They had things like
genocide, okay? This is all bad, right?
But remember, and this is really
important, okay?
These are just two different worldviews.
And it's hard for us to objectively
assess
which one is better. We can only say
that they both have their benefits and
they both have their
consequences.
Okay? So, an example is food.
If if we were to go to America today and
look at the food that Americans eat,
we'd be disgusted, right? Hamburgers,
Coca-Cola, french fries. But guess what,
guys? If Americans were to come to
China,
they would be equally disgusted by the
food that Chinese eat, okay? Like
malatang and and this stuff, okay? Some
of this stuff is really bad for you. So,
I would keep that in mind. It's easy for
us to be culturally arrogant and say
like we are so better than these
ancients.
But it's all a matter of perspective.
If we were to go back in time and look
at the pagan world, we'd be disgusted by
the murders, by the violence, by all the
sex going on, okay? But at the same
time, and this is really hard for us to
understand, but if they were to come
here, they were to time travel and come
here and see our world, they'd be
disgusted.
Okay? Because like from their
perspective, we behave like slaves.
Achilles is out winning glory on the
beaches of Troy, while we are in school
memorizing useless facts so that we can
get useless piece of paper pieces of
paper so that we can make useless pieces
of money, right? Money is paper. They
they will not understand why we're doing
this to ourselves. All right? So, I
would keep that in mind. Like the pagan
worldview is very different from the
Christian worldview and that's it.
All right? And in fact, we will later in
the semester discover that there are
some thinkers such as Nietzsche,
Friedrich Nietzsche,
who believe
that the switch from the pagan worldview
to the Christian worldview was a major
setback in the development of
civilization, okay?
All right. Any questions about the
difference between the pagans and
Christians before I move on?
Any questions?
Was this clear?
All right.
Now, let's move on to the idea of
republic versus empire.
Okay? And look, I mean,
the differences are pretty stark, right?
So, in a republic it's usually
there's there's like egalitarianism,
okay?
Everyone's opinion does matter.
And in an empire
there's a hierarchy.
Okay? So, that's the first major
difference, okay? In a republic people
are egalitarian.
And in an empire there's a hierarchy.
So, think think of this.
In the Persian empire,
if you were to meet the emperor, what
you have to do with what you have to do
was prostrate yourself first and then
kiss his feet.
All right? That's the idea of empire.
But in a republic you didn't do that.
In fact, even though
Rome was becoming a welfare city,
a major tradition in Rome was you didn't
lock your doors. You didn't have guards.
So, a senator who was in charge of Gaul,
he was literally he could literally put
loads of people to death if he wanted
to, he didn't lock his door. So, you,
the lowliest Roman, could just walk into
his house and have tea with him or
coffee with him and talk about
life, okay? That was the tradition in
Rome.
There's There's also another thing is
when Roman senators walked the streets
of Rome, they always carried an
umbrella, something called a
to protect themselves.
Okay? And the reason why is this?
Roman houses were two stories.
And they didn't have sewage system. So,
if you needed to go to the bathroom, you
did so using a bucket on the second
floor, okay?
And so what happened is if you saw
someone you didn't like walk the
streets, you would actually take your
bucket and throw all this at him,
okay? That's literally what they did.
So, if you were a senator,
you could be the most powerful man in
the world, but you could still literally
risk having thrown at you, okay?
So, that's the Roman world. It was
egalitarian. Whereas in an empire
there's hierarchy.
So, in an egalitarian world, it means
there's openness. People are open to new
ideas. There's debate. Okay? Literally
anyone could propose a new idea.
Whereas in the
empire, it was a very closed system,
okay?
They didn't like new ideas. So, go back
to the example of Greek fire,
right? A guy and it's a story so we
don't know if it's true, but a guy had
to go to the emperor and get his
approval before
the military could adopt it. That's
really inefficient, guys, okay? The
Greeks would have just gone and done it.
The Romans would have would have let the
commanders make their own decisions. It
would not have happened the decision of
the senate. It would have been the
decision of the military commander that
that was appointed by the senate.
Okay? So,
the republic would be much more
innovative than the empire because the
republic would be much more open, okay?
So,
um there'll be a lot more diversity
in a republic and
in a in a empire
things would be much more conformist.
Okay? You'll be you would have a lot
more creativity, a lot more diversity
within a republic than within an empire.
All right? And that's kind of intuitive
because if you think about it, empire
has so much more people and so much more
wealth and resources than a republic.
But at the but in historically we found
that republics and democracies are much
more innovative and creative than
empires. The reason has to do with the
idea of a bureaucracy.
All right? Something that a democracy
or a
republic does not have is the idea of an
imperial
bureaucracy.
All right? They have bureaucracies but
they're not that big and they're not
imperial. So,
let's talk about bureaucracy.
All right? And this is a very important
idea that I want you guys to remember
for the rest of the semester because we
will refer to this idea, right? Now,
in the beginning bureaucracies are good
for empires because because what they do
is they do centralization.
All right? They're able to
centralize the empire. Unite the empire
basically.
Something that they do that's important
is the idea of systematization.
All right?
Basically rec- keep records, uh create
laws, systematization. The last is the
idea of standardization.
Standardization.
Uniformity, okay?
So, getting people to speak the same
language, getting people to use the
metric system,
um getting people to use money, all
right?
And this creates tremendous wealth
within the empire in the early years
because again, what you have is you have
the creation of money
because you have a legal system
and you have a monopoly
on violence.
Monopoly on violence just means that
these neighbors don't fight anymore,
okay? Because there's a police.
There are these courts.
They can just sue each other. There's a
legal system and people are now using
money. Um this leads to contracts and
this leads to trade and increased
economic activity.
So, you have peace and prosperity.
People feel safe. Uh people feel that
life is predictable so they do more.
They work harder.
Okay? And this leads to in the early
stages of empire to tremendous
prosperity.
Okay?
But over time, what will happen is this
bureaucracy will ossify.
Meaning
the people in within the bureaucracy
will
think of how to use the bureaucracy for
their own personal benefit. Okay? We we
we we can say this is corruption, okay?
So, centralization leads to corruption.
Where it's just a minority people with
all the power use it for their own
personal benefit. They're basically
parasites. The the technical word we use
for this is rent-seeking, okay?
Rent-seeking.
So, think of landlords
who charge rent
to the tenants. Well, if it's a
monopoly, they can charge as much as
they want. There's nothing you can do
about it.
Okay? It's what it's what we call
rent-seeking.
So, centralization eventually leads to
corruption.
Systematization
leads to ultimately stagnation.
Okay? There's nothing new
um going on. And centralization leads to
the idea of conformity or homon-
homogenization, okay? Where everything
becomes the same. Where everything's the
where everything is bland.
All right?
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay.
So, why this happens
is
because
even though the bureaucracy is only an
institution among different
institutions, okay? So, think about
this. You have the imperial bureaucracy
but they are competing against the court
system, okay? Which is basically the
emperor. Okay? And the court is usually
controlled by eunuchs, okay? So, these
are servants of the emperor. The
bureaucracy is up against the court.
It's also up against the nobility,
right? The traditional power of society.
It's also up against the military.
It's also up against the church.
Okay? So, there are different
um institutions that can counter the
bureaucracy. But over time in terms of
peace and prosperity, if things are
really stable, eventually the
bureaucracy triumphs over all these
other institutions.
Okay? And the reason why is this?
First is
the bureaucracy can monopolize
status.
Okay?
And mobility.
So, if you're just an ordinary person
well,
the best way
to rise in a society is through the
bureaucracy. This is certainly true in
China, right?
Where everyone wants to be a be a
bureaucrat because that's a seen as the
mechanism of achieving social status as
well as social mobility.
Also,
bureaucracies monopolize
information.
It controls what information flows into
the system. It controls what the emperor
sees.
Okay? So, we so we can say this is about
censorship
and secrecy.
And the last thing that it does is it
monopolizes the idea of narrative.
Okay?
It
it controls the production of culture.
And we can
uh so, and it does this mainly through
the process of writing history.
Okay? So, remember history is the
creation of a cultural narrative to bind
people together. It's usually the
imperial bureaucrats who do this.
In other words, what's important for us
to understand is
the bureaucrats have a monopoly
of literacy
and knowledge.
They control the schools. They control
the media. They control history writing.
They control how you think and um write.
So, even though these are
they're competing institutions, the
bureaucracy by controlling this
meta-reality that's culture, it controls
the way
like these
um other institutions
behave, okay? So,
um the example I want to use is the idea
of the godhead.
All right? The godhead.
So, my argument to you is the godhead is
really a bureaucratic invention.
All right?
Because remember, um in during the
Council of
Nicaea
Nicaea,
there's a debate as to the nature of
Jesus. There are these Arians who
believe that Jesus was a lesser
divinity.
Then there were people called uh who
believed in modalism who who just
believed the Holy Spirit, Jesus, and God
were dif- were different forms of the
same entity.
Then you have partialism which would say
that they are part of the same entity,
okay? And these three different
explanations make sense. Make they make
intuitive sense.
The idea of the godhead where
God,
Jesus,
and the Holy Spirit
are
co-equal, separate, but the same thing
makes no sense.
And the reason why they would do this is
to create a sense of mystery,
right? And distance.
And secrecy.
And that, my friends, is the definition
of a bureaucracy.
All right?
I'm not sure if you dealt with
bureaucracies. I have. They suck. They
dehumanize you. So, think of
I I I I'll just use use a silly example,
right? So, in America, there's there's
something called a census.
And on the census, you have to write
down what racial group you belong to.
And the racial group racial group I
belong to, if I were American, is Asian
American.
Right? Guess what? Guess who else
belongs in that group? Indian people.
Vietnamese people. Japanese people.
Korean people.
That makes no sense. We know that in in
uh Asia, the Indian culture is vastly
different from the Japanese culture
which is vastly different from the
Korean
culture and the Chinese culture and the
Vietnamese culture, okay? These are
different people with their own
um belief systems.
But in a bureaucracy,
it just categorizes everyone together
almost randomly
or indifferently.
Okay?
And that's why I will I will make the
argument that ultimately multicultural
societies
are not
as creative as
as tribal societies.
Okay? Tribal versus multicultural.
Think about the multicultural societies
that are around us today, okay?
Singapore is a multicultural society.
Canada is a multicultural society.
They're not very creative, guys. They're
very bland. They're very conformist.
They're very bureaucratic.
Okay?
Very tribal societies like the Greeks
The Greeks were extremely
tribal. They're extremely chauvinistic.
They were extremely creative.
Right? As were
um
as were the Europeans, okay?
As were the Vikings.
And the reason why is tribalism
is energetic. It makes you passionate.
It makes you think deeply about the
world.
Whereas in in a multicultural society
people
have to spend their energies getting
along with with with each other. It's
important not to be offensive.
Okay?
And so it's because of these three
uh reasons that certain the certain
cultural construct of the Byzantine
Empire
uh it was Christian.
It was multicultural. Uh the word we can
also use we can also use is
cosmopolitan, okay? Um also it was
bureaucratic. The Byzantines were not a
very creative people.
Okay? Even though they had access to
every culture in the world, even though
they had access to the classics
like Plato, Homer, Herodotus, as well as
Virgil, they were not that creative.
In fact, if you had a genius like Homer
or Dante living in the Byzantine Empire
well
he would just become a bureaucrat.
We would never know the genius of Homer
and Dante.
Homer and Dante could only arise in
tribal societies.
Okay?
So
that
um
yeah. So does that make sense to you
guys?
Okay? And again, this is this is an
introduction
to the conflict with between these
political systems.
Empire versus Republic, bureaucracy
versus um
um yeah.
Right? We will continue uh these themes
and these topics as we
uh move on throughout um Western
history. But I I first want to introduce
these ideas to you. It's really
important that you understand the
difference between between paganism and
Christianity because we'll be referring
uh to this conflict, this division later
on in the semester as well.
Any questions about this?
Please feel free to argue, okay?
Please feel free
to ask questions, to argue um because
when you do that, it helps me improve my
own thinking.
Right?
Any comments?
Any feedback?
Okay. So um I want I want to give you
some guys some time to think about
questions, but before I do that, I want
to I want to look ahead over the next
couple weeks and tell you what we'll be
doing, okay?
So we we did the Roman Empire, then we
did the Byzantines. So um as I explained
to you, the Roman Empire
uh Western Roman Empire will collapse
in the year 476
when the last emperor Romulus Augustulus
is deposed, okay?
But when he is deposed
people don't understand the Roman Empire
has come to an end.
Okay? Because um the people who are
still in charge think the Roman Empire
is continuing. But now we have a long
period of civil wars throughout
Europe.
All right? And these civil wars will
eventually lead to something called the
Holy Roman Empire, which is something
that the uh which which which is what
Charlemagne of the Franks will create.
And this will lead, interesting for us,
to the to the rise of the Vikings.
Okay? Okay? Now Vikings are important
because they will go on and basically
influence British culture
as well as
Russian culture.
All right? So Russia comes from the idea
of the Rus, okay? Now Rus are basically
just Vikings.
Um
over here we will begin we will see the
beginning of the Abbasid Caliphate,
which is really the golden age
of
the um
Muslims.
But eventually they'll be conquered by
the Mongols.
All right?
And the conquest of the Mongols will
eventually take us into the Renaissance,
Dante.
And this will mark a a new beginning in
world history, okay? So I I just want to
explain to you what we what we'll be
doing. We will definitely have to do
um the Holy Roman Empire, that's number
one. Then this will lead us to the
Vikings, number two. Then then we'll
talk about the Abbasid Caliphate, number
three. And then we'll talk about the
Mongols and then the Renaissance, okay?
So this is what we'll be doing over the
next
two to three weeks.
All right? We'll be going very fast
throughout uh we'll be going very fast
uh this semester, okay? So just let you
know.
All right?